Avengers 4 is right around the corner
it's getting real close and with that
we're starting to get a ton of leaked
information leaked set photos leaked
concept art toys actors are getting
asked questions about the movie in
interviews they do on TV and on social
media and last week a supposed trailer
description was leaked well this week we
have another one and this one is even
more believable than the first one I'm
still giving away copies of infinity war
and ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as
well as some special edition posters all
you have to do to enter the giveaway is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero ok so just like
last time I'm going to read you the full
trailer description final trailer is
about two ish minutes it starts with a
tenth year logo which zooms into the
screen in logo fashion but it flashes
all colors of the stones as it does
thanassis voice my destiny is not yet
fulfilled a shot of battered Tony looks
as though he's still on Titan confused
Dennis's voice again greater threats
arise to undo the balance i lost
everything to achieve and i will not be
undone shot of banner and cap with
vision on a table fades in and out shots
of quill ship lifting off fades tony
says fury was right he's talking to
someone out of view in some type of
normal house this might be on May
he's glassy-eyed and the dialogue is
spoken over the prior screen not
actually what he's saying Tony says
again he was right since day 1 black
screen this next scene is of Tony it's a
scene of him in some sort of garage
looking place in front of him are three
different suits that seem pretty normal
none are the ones that were leaked he
has the housing units in his hand he
says I'll do whatever it takes so that
never happens again
black scream and then Tony is in shield
gear he's walking towards the camera
with soldiers behind him shot of ant-man
standing in the quantum realm it cuts to
him surrounded by three tardigrades
he's running then stops at a green
portal type thing fades the shot of
Scott and Street close grey shirt jeans
and a jacket Scott says I think I might
have a way to hell
shot of an empty throne in Wakanda
various shots of Shuri mbaku and a coy
black screen Shuri or a co e says this
was not our fight
cuts to a shot of captain standing arms
cross with rody rocket and Thor in a
room that looks like it's still Wakanda
captain says we need to make this right
banner says cap we don't even know where
to start
Thanos is gone he won then Thor says
well then we had better get to work
Schatz panting down slowly of the pager
fury hat in someone's hands the user
that leaked this said they are almost
100% certain that it's in Tony's hands
it goes to a shot of Rhodey suiting up
very briefly and it's not nanotech but
it looks more or less exactly how star
Lord's mask materializes we hear Thor's
voice say are you ready for this fades
to black and we hear Rockets say well if
I'm not the music stops and it fades
back in and we see rocket and he says
what more could I lose shot of the
Bifrost with Thor war machine and rocket
various shots gauntlet still damaged
being reached for shot of nebula looks
like the same place Tony was earlier and
then a shot of banner black screen we
then have a scene where Thor says we
need an army to stand against Thanos it
then shows a shot of Thanos putting on
armor we hear Thor's voice again say
yours is the only formidable enough to
give us a chance shows a shot of Thanos
wielding a big double-edged sword
Thor says again so I asked you various
shots of Black Widow brief shot of Tony
suit caps new chess piece which is
chainmail and banner putting on a purple
skin tight suit and a button-up over it
in front of a mirror fades to Thor we
hear him say will you help us more
various shots including a broken
gauntlet on the ground as someone who is
clearly Thanos is walking away same
aesthetic and scenery as the one when
it's being reached for the person
walking away then says it's been a while
since I've been to earth music is
getting louder as it crescendos to a
shot of Captain Marvel the scenery
behind her almost looks like Xander it's
blue skies and clouds outside a window
Captain Marvel says let's go then it
shows a shot of her fly
towards something angrily she [ __ ] back
a punch eyes glowing flames surrounded
her she punches then the title card
appears as The Avengers theme plays
however it doesn't actually have
anything it's just a blank screen with
music post theme cutaway stinger rocket
is in a rolling chair looking at a few
computer screens has on this cool white
bodysuit Rhodey says I've seen a lot of
crazy things but a talking raccoon
rocket then looks up at him from the
chair and Rhodey says definitely tops
them all rocket going from Rhodey back
to the computer screen sarcastically boy
if I had a unit every time I heard that
one cuts to a shot of Thor smiling with
an off cue ha ha ha trailer ends so that
is it for this new Avengers 4 trailer
description leak it's certainly a lot
more believable than the first one that
we heard and this leaker apparently
claims to have predicted the appearance
of spider-man in the Captain America
civil war trailer and red skull surprise
cameo and infinity war and even though
leaks are common this close to trailers
actually being released you never know
so take it with a grain of salt so let
me know all of your thoughts about this
new supposed Avengers 4 trailer leak in
the comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date with everything related to
Avengers 4 thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]